cinéma maintenant et la science fiction
ne se limite pas à star wars le jeune
réalisateur français cédric klapisch a
en effet imaginé ce que pourrait être la
vie en 2070 dans un paris envahi par le
sable un jeune homme rencontre ses
descendants le film s'intitule peut être
dominique poncet jean christophe duclos
un jeune homme qui passe une soirée de
réveillon le 31 décembre 1999 et qui se
retrouvent brutalement propulsé en l'an
2000 70
que découvre-t-il non pas raymond
déshumanisé et plein de soucoupes
volantes mais ses propres enfants et
petits enfants vivent dans un univers de
sable mon circulent à dos d'ânes et de
chameau pour faire tenir debout cette
histoire abracadabrante et surtout
convaincre des comédiens plus confirmés
de la défendre il fallait s'appeler à
cédric klapisch de wierre moi ça m'a plu
tout de suite parce que je compterai
dans un univers tout à fait étrange et
bizarre et décalé aussi car lorsque le
jeune héros du fils découvre ses enfance
comme il s'est écoulé 70 ans ils sont
évidemment plus âgés que lui
qu'est ce que vous voulez on veut
exister oui surtout pour les ampoules
belmondo donjon incarnant le fils d'un
trentenaire il fallait le faire
dossiers des jeunes hommes à qui j'ai
fait j'ai eu à dire papa est ce que je
vais pouvoir faire ça sans rigoler 5e ça
et ça semble impossible
et finalement quand on va tourner et
j'ai ça s'est passé très très bien qu'on
sent dans ses yeux qu'il a envie de
jouer qui n'a envie de vous appeler papa
ça faisait beau coréen
donc ça c'est mon appris assez vite ça
avec plaisir quoi d'avoir ce rapport là
tous les deux les en dehors de leur
plaisir d'acteur ce qui a surtout plu à
belmondo ya du risque c'est cette vision
du monde de demain que propose klapisch
avec un joyeux culot un monde métissé
chaleureux et sans violence
je pense qu'il est parti dans cette
histoire ce qu'ils voulaient faire rêver
les gens et montrer que on avait encore
des rêves quoi et
et dans le rêve c'est optimiste vos
klapisch
sous les pavés d'aujourd'hui il y a donc
demain la plage si seulement vous pouvez
rêver vrai une dernière